i've made other types of films i've
definitely done stunts before and things
like that the whole energy of this movie
is something different than i've been a
part of what can i do you for it and
truly michael bay is the reason i wanted
to make this film
get out
get out now i mean i always love a
mixture of a challenge in the physical
world and also in the emotional world
i could use some help my wife needs to
search me yeah we need something you
call me huh i left because that life
wasn't good for me
will and danny grew up as brothers but
no one really considers them brothers
because will is adopted the two of them
have been avoiding each other for a
while but will he's frustrated and he's
looking for a way out to help his family
how much do you need
231. how about more
i wanted to create a real brother
relationship with yaya full of all the
messiness those types of relationships
have you're my brother i love you i will
do anything for you and all i'm asking
is whether you're in you're out
let's go d suspects have hijacked a red
and white ambulance what i love about
working with michael bay is he has a
real reverence for actors he respects
the process and he drives towards the
energy of a scene when something's
happening he runs right towards it okay
this is fun ready and action
we're doing stunts with helicopters
flying under bridges and i'm sticking my
head out of an ambulance driving at 60
miles an hour
a movie like this belongs in the theater
i cannot wait we're not the bad guys
there is nothing like it
we're just the guys trying to get home
[Music]
you